welcome to this video black again why
I'm always black okay holla holla boo ha
ha whoo ha I tried to play in a lickin
my hand offense but he declined it okay
oops no not the king hey good that I
don't play with smart walking his son
would be rather embarrassing him let's
see I'm just developing vzm okay he
wants to move his night a couple of
times now but he's getting the bishop
pair so maybe I should have addressed
that you can take now and maybe play
something like nighty too and then a
quick deform which looks quite nice for
white how can i irritate and maybe with
with age 5 h for stuff like that let's
try that it's it's a little bit dicey
maybe but but interesting to try now hy
he plays g4 hmm okay let me try
something really really wacky d 4 i'm
going nite h7 trying to play for this
for this for the structure it's probably
nothing you should try at home but what
I'm trying to do is get to a position
where he has a really bad bishop on g2
the draw big is of course that I have
him in my development the night on age 7
all this looks really crazy so I have
some doubts about the whole concept but
may be interesting to try the position
is very close so it's not clear that you
can punish me um quickly for it if I
have some if he gives me some some some
time i'm going to regroup the night to
g6 this is the next
here note that i have all the parts on
dark squares and paw a bishop on on c8 i
think what he's doing is exactly that he
prepares long castles hmm I was thinking
that maybe 96 as an idea here after d
595 I can go Quinn b5 help ok so
shouldn't do that probably here are then
I guess Knight c3 ok I can I can play
this move it's not a problem that
interesting is taking here hmm yeah hmm
not sure both captures come into
consideration and then he wants to play
93-95 but I have 94 ok Knight c3 a half
94 which is very important otherwise I i
was i would be in real trouble ok so
night d 5 I need to prevent that and I
can go see six I can do that right very
important or is there better move even
there should be six ninety-five nap I
need to do this
yeah interesting interesting strategic
ideas if I go Bishop is 623 rock the
eight simply yeah maybe why not I can
maybe retreat all the way where do I go
then with monoid it still should be okay
that still still should be okay I mean
everyone I was thinking but here I
thought rook the aid or maybe even long
castling why not why not actually I can
do that so the whole strategy which was
a little bit artificial somehow worked
worked out fine yeah I have a nice
position now with this Bishop on g2
being a real problem peace and have an
excellent structure really wow I'm
absolutely not believing any of that but
that's not working no no way um Bishop
t5r this this is night hanging on g6 wow
wow okay sorry about that so really
stunned here that this is possible okay
i can do to f7 actually if you go c 3 i
have this check
that's bit weird yeah that's not very
harmonious ha what do we get idea but
it's not totally clear especially
considering that we are playing blitz am
rook e1 is a move that I'm a bit worried
about okay it's not going for it these
six seven I need to I really want to
prevent the pawn for advancing even if I
need to block it with the Queen which is
not ideal but I get night afore in and
then rook e8 get my get my pieces
coordinated I'm a piece up for two pawns
so right that's a good move probably
activating as Bishop a bit but it's not
helping him very much on f5 what is this
Bishop actually doing um okay okay
want to play rookie 5 getting even more
pressure on the on the pawn and I want
to catch up on the clock that's very
important I was really down a lot
timewise okay get out of this check and
maybe I can this is also protecting f6
and then can play something like or
should i just go Bishop g6 trade this
off now that's actually a good
configuration what if i just take this
by the way just take this yeah that's
that's just good I spent too much time
on this actually it's just a very simple
way to continue the H bonus is really a
winner
12 look b5 I can take and the text see
form yeah and there is the H porn and
this is too much it really should be too
much wants to take on b6
brah Alfred I know it is slightly tricky
right slightly tricky is funnier oh man
what did i do here against this utter
nonsense unbelievable they just can take
f7 and i'm lost them unbelievable check
at these seven wins i don't know what
he's doing here maybe just check wants
to toy with me or anything check check
and believe that stuff ah resigns wow I
mean how did I screw this up that wasn't
easy I mean how do I defend now this
this should still be a total win right I
can just take it for here ah come on why
don't I do that it's very easy right
just take this and he resigns oh man ah
yeah and then this is it that said I
mean this is just just no attack
whatsoever oh come on this is this is
just just just bad yo now what I also
did it I spent hard too much time around
here when he was giving up this piece
for no particular reason I mean wide
already was was a little bit outplayed
of course but still it's just really
giving up a piece it took me a while to
really see Bishop f7 but then yeah I
mean this is just a total win but I
screwed it up okay thanks for watching